President Trump is already making a huge
impact on the nation's courts just one
year into his turn with help from
Republicans in the Senate the president
won confirmation for twenty three
federal judges including a Supreme Court
justice 12 Circuit Court judges and 10
district court judges that one year
total is far more than the number
President Obama appointed at this point
in his presidency Jan Crawford is
outside the Supreme Court Jan good
morning well good morning John I mean
you know a Supreme Court nomination I
mean that can be a president's most
lasting legacy and although president
sharp has had a contentious relationship
at times with the federal judiciary he's
already made a lasting impact he's put
one justice on the Supreme Court nearly
two dozen judges on the lower courts and
that is just in year one good president
Trump nominated judge Neal Gorsuch to
the Supreme Court he delivered on a key
campaign promise to replace the late
Justice Antonin Scalia with a solid
conservative you got to go for Trump
Supreme Court justices in 2016 56% of
Republican voters said the Supreme Court
was the most important factor in their
support for Donald Trump but the White
House is also making its mark on the
lower course where the president is
looking to fill 145 vacancies nationwide
what the president's doing with the
courts is truly transformative Leonard
Leo is an outside adviser to the
President on judges and helps lead the
conservative Federalist Society these
are people who believe in
self-government that most of the big
issues in our country need to be decided
by the people and their elected
representatives there have been missteps
at the district court level have you
ever tried a jury trial
I have not civil no two of the
president's nominees were forced to
withdraw over questions about their
qualifications but on the appeals
court's the new judges are highly
credentialed conservative powerhouses
what you'd expect from a traditional
Republican president Democrats say it's
not qualifications but their philosophy
that could lead to a rollback of civil
rights an alarming trend of more and
more extreme judicial candidates we have
seen president Trump nominate people far
outside of the judicial mainstream the
goal is not
to get a few ultra-conservative judges
on our federal courts it is to capture
the entire judicial branch Leo says the
judicial battles show elections have
consequences the president made it very
clear the kinds of people he was going
to nominate and that's what he's
delivering now with Republicans in
control the Senate filling those 145
vacancies clearly is within reach but if
Democrats take back the Senate that
could complicate things especially if
another justice retires while President
Trump is still in office Gail it's
always interesting thank you very much
Jan